abone ol
ya
oralar sanırım görüyorum oğlum
robotistan de sarı paylaşım
yapabileceğim Evet
Sparrow hemen hemen tane görebiliyor
musunuz arkadaşlar
Evet
önceki nazik davetiniz için teşekkür
ediyorum sağolun
yukarıdan gelen
katılımcılara benim etmez etmeme gerek
yok değil mi komposta olarak
yapabiliyorsunuz
Evet evet o iş Bizde hiç merak etmeyin
ama ki süper
Bak bu genç arkadaşlarımız bana
geldiklerinde Yankı temalı bir şey
yapmak istediklerini söylediler Ben de
buna Gılgamış Lala cevap olayım istedim
Çünkü Gılgamış yazılı tarihin bilinen
ilk Destanı ilk kahramanlık her yerde
Peki bu öykünün yankıyla nasıl bir
ilişkisi var Ben Gılgamış Destanı'nın
varlığını
Binlerce yıl sonra nasıl bir yankıyla
tekrar vücut bulduğu üzerinden bir
şeyler anlatmak istiyorum birkaç tane de
görsel Göstereceğim size bilmeyenler
içinde kısa bir ön açıklama yapayım
saniye
arkadaşlar Gılgamış bildiğimiz kadarıyla
mezopotamya'nın Grup şehrinde
Mezopotamya dediğiniz yer neresi
Mezopotamya yani bizlere Fırat nehirleri
arasında kalan ülke anlamına geliyor ya
da nehirler arası ülke anlamına geliyor
Burada ise yaklaşık olarak bağladık
buralarda hesap ederseniz Bağdat'ın
güneyinde Basra Körfezi'nin kuzeyinde
antik bir şehirde euroluk üzerindeki
buyruk şehrini Siz günümüzde de asla
sıkça duyuyorsunuz nerede duyuyorsunuz
bırak diye bildiğiniz ülkenin ismi asla
luluk isminden gelir Eren bu olarak
değişir başka birisi de var Kadır burada
Krallık yapmış olan gılgamış'ın milattan
önce 2902 1400'lü yıllarda yaşamış
olduğunu düşünüyoruz Çağdaş metninin
olmadığını biliyoruz Bu da bizim için
Önemli bir detay Neden Çünkü Çağdaş
Metin varsa bir karakter üzerine Bu
tarihe girer destan ve efsane MİT
ornitoloji değildir Çünkü onun ölümünden
Birkaç yıl sonra bir şeyler yazarsanız
bunun objektif olmasının bir dayanağı
yoktur bir elle tutulur taraf yoktur
Bundan dolayı fantastik bir karakter
olarak karşımıza çıkıyor Birçok yerde
Gılgamış en çok ne ile karşımızda 3 rüya
görüyor çok megaloman tuttuğunu koparan
efendime söyleyeyim tozu dumana katan
dil bir adam halk bundan şikayetçi dir
çok özet anlatıyorum arkadaşlar Çünkü
ben bunu Normalde 3 aylıktır
dilimlerinde fal ne anlatıyorum
halkından çok şikayetçidir tam vardı onu
şikayet ederler Tanrılar da onu
cezalandırmak için enkidu adında bir
Barlık yaratırlar ve uru atarlar Bunlar
karşılaşır kısa zamanda dost olurlar
kavga ettikten sonra tabii ki daha sonra
tanrılara kafa tutarlar bomba diye bir
tanrı öldürürler iştahla beraber olmak
istemez İştar göklerin bu aslını
gönderir Gılgamış onu öldürür Tanrılar
Gılgamış su cezalandırmak için en
sevdiğim en değer verdiği biriciği olan
eki duyurdu renkli duyma ile öldürür bir
sivrisineği öldürürler yani sıkmaya
yakalanır yedi gün yedi gece ateşler
içinde yatar Sonra ölür sonra 12 gün
ölüsü bekletilir ve ölür Gılgamış da bu
ölüm üzerine bir ölümsüzlük yolculuğuna
çıkar
ölümsüzlüğün peşine düşer ve dünya
tarihinde ilk kez Nuh Tufanı duymaya
başlarız benimse buraya kadar olan kısım
klasik Ilgaz ve mitolojide Gılgamış
Destanı çok da önemli değil farklı bir
şekilde ele alıyor muyum Evet nasıl ele
alıyorum ben Gılgamış bir türlü seni
iktidar halk Doğa medeniyet nerede Ertal
homosapiyens çizgiler üzerinden ele
alıyorum Aslında böyle ilgili böyle
dokunulması böyle incelenmesi
gerektiğine inanıyorum ki bununla ilgili
de yazdım bir tiyatro oyunu var 9 Martta
Brüksel'de kimse varsa dinleyeceğiz da
bekliyoruz iyiyim ve çık akaliye
tiyatrosunda oynanacak bir oyuna
dönüştürdük bu fiyatlarımız gılgamış'ın
günümüzdeki Ya kısmıdır arkadaşlar
Gılgamış Her şeyden önce kendisine bazı
tanımlamalar yapıyor diyor ki ben yarı
Tanrı yarı insanım dünya insanlık
tarihinde yazılı olarak ilk kez bir kral
kendisini Yaratanın yarı insan ilan
ediyor buradan Neyi çıkaracaksınız
günümüzde varlık göstermiş olan Kraliyet
sorularının tamamının bu kendilerinin
kutsal bir Soydan kutsal ve seçilmiş
birkandan gelme argümanını İlk Sesi
Gılgamış Yankı kendileridir Yani bugün
Kraliçe Elizabeth et ya da Prens şans
Bunların hepsi gılgamış'ın yan kısmının
sonuçlarıdır arkadaşlar veya Fatih
Sultan Mehmet Yavuz Sultan Selim
Aklımdaki göre Sevda Muhteşem Süleyman
Bunların hepsi bu adamın bu kralın
kendisinin bu şekilde tanımlaması ile
ilgilidir Benim babam bir bahçıvan veya
dağlarda yaşayan bir gariban iken Annem
tanrıça
uzaktır ve ben tam senin kursaktan olma
yarı tarih yarı insan kutsal kalitesi
temsil eden birisi Gılgamış
Destanı'nda ölümsüzlüğü arama
hikâyesinde aslında bana sorarsanız
ölümü ve ölmeyi öğreten bir kral Çünkü
inançlar insanların
bu doğru hürriyetlerin den Doğan
şeylerdir ölümü kabul etmemek hayatın
sonuçlanacağı ağır düşüncesine mağlup
olmamak için siz yeni bir şey sığınak
alan yaratırsınız ve biz buna inanç
temiz ama inançların dine dönüşmesi
iktidarların ihtiyacıdır bireylerin
insanların değil Sizin bireysel olarak
din inancınızın herhangi bir dünya din
ideoloji ve inancıyla evdeki olmaması
gayet büyük Çünkü inanç sizin ihtiyaç
duyup inşa ettiğiniz bir sığınak sadin
birilerini sizi bir alanda toplayıp
sizden istifade etme alanına dönüşebilir
Gılgamış böyle bir şey de yaratıyor
Gılgamış diyor ki ölmekten kaçamazsınız
ölmekten kaçamıyor sanız ölümden sonraki
hayatın garantisi elde etmemiz lazım
bunların yolu nereden geçer tanrılara ve
Tanrıların dünyadaki Allah sevgisi olan
kurallara bağlılık ve itaat tanışır
Bundan dolayı herkesin ölümsüzlük
yolculuğu olarak okuduğu Gılgamış
Destanı bana sorarsanız bir ölmeyi
öğrenme yolculuğudur öyle ölmeyi öğrenme
yolculuğunda elde edeceğine edeceğiniz
en büyük çıktı kurala dolaşır arı Tanrı
olan bağlarımızın biraz daha pişmesi
Zirve burada uzun uzun alıntılar var Ben
çok fazla Bunlar üzerinde durmayacağım
arkadaşlar sadece gılgamış'ın günümüz
Dünyası asla şurada bir iki gönderme
yapabiliriz
gılgamış'ın günümüzdeki yankısı Aslında
ne demiştim bir yandan da doğa ve
medeniyetin birbiriyle olan şeydir
ilişkisidir Gılgamış kendi namını
dünyaya yaymak için kız ölümsüzlüğünü
gücünü ispat etmek için sedir
ormanlarının bekçisi olan kum babayı
öldürmek ister kum bu durmak iste renkli
ona karşı çıkar ama bir sürü onu
yolundan cayılamaz ve ve onlara göre
sedir ağaçlarının dağlarına doğru yola
çıkarlar günümüzde Lübnan dağları
olduğunu düşünüyoruz burada humam
öldürür Peki bu Baba neydi asla neyi
temsil ediyordu diye bana sorarsanız
bumbaba Her şeyden önce doğanın
kendisiydi ve Hım babayla karşılaşmak
hasta gılgamış'ın kendi ikiyle olan bir
mücadelenin
sonucu Çünkü Gılgamış bomba boya her
saldırdığında oğlum babanın 7 8'e
girdiğini ve yedi farklı
bu güçle yedi farklı kötülükle Gılgamış
a saldırdığında gılgamış'ın Her seferde
Bunlardan birisi yok ettiğini
öğreniyoruz nedir bu kıskançlık
açgözlülük ki bir efendime söyleyeyim
öfke
Bu ücret yalan söylemek Bunların hepsi
asla gılgamış'ın çıktığı bir yolculukta
ki iş dünyasına refere etmekle beraber
burada
ormanları koruyan bir varlık üzerindeki
renklendiriliyor akıl gamış sedir
ormanlarının bekçisi olan Baba'yı
öldürdüğünde onu kellesini alıp uzağa
götürüyor bize bunu anlatıyor destan ama
bana sorarsan son metaforik bir şeyden
bahsediyor Gılgamış kendi inşa ettiği
şehrin varlığı için doğayı daha barbarca
bir şekilde kat etmeye başlıyor çünkü
sizin kutladığınız Eğer insansa teolojik
ve teorik olarak insanın varlığı için
doğada kurban edilmeyecek hiçbir şey
yoktur
kendimden örnek vereyim Arkadaşlar ben
bu yılbaşına kadar yani
2021 kastediyorum 22 değil Benim için
insan olması önemlidir ya diyordum
insansa ya bu sonra bir şekilde ortak
nokta bulunur falan bunda aslında ne
kadar barbarca bir doğa ilişkisi inşa
ettiğini fark ettim çünkü insan ise
benim için yeterlidir dediğim andan
itibaren insan olmayan her şeyin
insandan daha değersiz olduğunu da
söylüyorum Bir yandan da bu çok önemli
bir nokta Bundan dolayı benim kutlamam
bu önemsemem gereken şey insan değil
yaşamın kendisi olduğunu fark ettim ya
sonra bahçemdeki erik ağacıyla benim
dünyadaki varlığımda teraziye
koyduğumuzda bir farkımız yok O benden
daha önemli olabilir havayı temizliyor o
toprağa gübre diyor
birçok hayvan için yiyecek üretebiliyor
Ben Aksi gibi bir Predator olarak
sürekli yok ediyorum Gılgamış burada
bizim bu yönümüzde de Yüzleşme mizin
önünü açıyor ve Gılgamış diyor ki ben
şehri Yücel için ormanın koruyucusu olan
en büyük ağaçları burada kastediyoruz
şey feda edebilirim onunla Saraylar
yatırabilirim onunla katlar inşa
edebilir vesaire Nitekim enkidu da
öyledir arkadaşlar yani şöyle yukarı
doğru gelirsen tekrar enkidu onu
Gılgamış da karşılaşmadan önce Tüm
hayvanları anlar konusu onlarla
hayvanlar en kiloyu anlayıp konuşabilir
bizleri iletişimleri vardır ne zaman ki
bir tapınak bak rahibesi bazı
kaynaklarda fahişesi olarak geçer gelir
yedi gün yedi gece enkidu ile beraber
olur en kutsal bir adam içer insanın
temel varlığı olan ekmekten yer çok
metaboli göndermeler vardır Tek tanrılı
Mona testilere Bunlar yedikten sonra
rahibe kızmaya başladı atıyor ceylanlar
benden kaçıyor kardeşlerim Aslanlar
benimle aynı yerden su içmeye başladı
Ben onları anlamaya başladım bunu sulu
anlıyoruz Doğan bu içerisinde
edeb ağırlığı Ağır ol ham olan hiçbir
şey sizi doğadan koparmaz yani sonra
erik ağacının üzerine çıkıp olgunlaşmış
birer eklediğimde Ben doğanın içerisinde
bir bütünleşik eylem gerçekleştirmiş
oluyorum ama ben onu oradan koparıp Ateş
yakıp üstüne koyduğumda daha önce
topladım ve kuruttum şeker kamışlarından
elde ettim şekerle karıştırıp bir erik
marmelatı yaptığında ben dünyada var
olmayan bir şeyleri bir araya getirip
kompozit bir şeyler üretmeye başlıyorum
dur ve ben doğada
doğalında yanina türünde gelişen sür kül
asyonu kırıyorum dur Gılgamış biraz bize
bunları ekibi üzerinden anlatıyor enkidu
bira içmeye başladı Ekiliyor arpa
verirseniz sarhoş olmaz ama en ki Duyar
mayalanmış arpa suyu içilir seni sarhoş
olur aikido sadece buğday görürse yemez
ama enkidu kaynat Bu büyütülüp
hamur hale getirip ateşte pişirilen
buğdayı yerse ekmeği yerse yani başka
bir şey dönüştürülen ile tanışır şişmeye
başlar ihtiyacından fazla yediği için ve
bunu bir sosyal aktivite hale getirdiği
için kilo almaya başlayacaktır Doğan
çizgisinin dışına çıkmaya başlayacak
biraz bize bunu da Anlatmaya başlıyor
bir yerde balgamış Destanı bizim bu ilk
çıkan sesten bunu öyle okuyun lütfen
Ben neyi okumamız gerekir asla
gılgamış'ın da Öncesinde bir ses var
Başka bir konu olabilir göbeklitepe'de
aslında iftar insan ilişkisi üzerine
baskı ile söylememize resmi olabilir Ama
o yazı olmadığı için yüzünüze yıl Gamze
dönüyoruz İlk Kan ses de biz onu değil
yankılarını duyuyoruz Biz Neyi duyuyoruz
doğada istediğimizi yapabiliriz örnek
veriyorum Şu anda maden yatak o önemi
için Türkiye'de zeytin ağaçları kesilip
maden aramasına izin verildi dünyanın
hiçbir ülkesinde böyle bir şey yoktur bu
gılgamış'ın kestiği ağacın
karşılığıdır yankısız arkadaşlar Eğer bu
hikaye gılgamış'ın değil En ki durum
olsaydı yani aklı bir çizgide olsaydı
burada Gılgamış da ama Safiye eski
dinlerler hali temsil eder bana göre bir
zeytin ağaçlarını kesmekten ziyade daha
fazla zeytin ağacı ekmeye başladı Bundan
dolayı ilk çıkan sesin yankısı nın
ilk sesle karşılaştırılması gerektiğine
inanıyorum iktidarların sorgulanması
gerektiğine inanıyorum doğa ile olan
ilişkimizi sorgulanması gerektiğine
inanıyorum ve bizim tarihi yeni bir
perspektifle tekrar okumamız gerekiyor
Çünkü mitolojiler arkadaşlar
boşluklardan mi teşekkür olan
metinlerdir bu metinler her soğan geri
gereklilikleri ve zaruri bu
yüksekliğinde doldurulur ve kullanılır
bu Onları zaten ölümsüz bir nokta
yatırır eğer biz de 45 bin yıldır yazılı
bir bellek ile Kollektif bir hafıza
aracılığıyla bize aktarılmış olan
binlerce yıllık mitleri efsaneleri
destanları Ve Tanrı öykülerini başka bir
gözle dünyanın daha yaşanır bir hale
dönüştürülmesi umudu ve gözüyle ele
alırsa Bence Geçmişe dair yeni bir
hafıza elde etmiş olur geleceği de
okunması gereken bir Manifesto bırakmış
oluruz Bu manifestonun ilk adımları
yanlış atılmış olabilir neanderthal den
homosapiense kadar yanlış atılmış
olabilir ateşin ortaya çıkması aydınlık
ve kendimizi korumak iken bugün
milyonlarca insanın ölümüne vesile
olabilen ölümcül silahlara dönüşebiliyor
Bu da doğada yoktur mesela
hiçbir ayı sürüsü veya çıta sürüsü
durduk yere kendi alanı gel Allah kuluna
başka bir süre saldırmaz kendi
varlıklarını teminat altında tutmak
üzere bir hayat pratiği sevgilerle bu
destanları efsaneleri mitosları bu
öyküleri bu masalları
bu ekolojik
mentalite ile okursak bir yere
varabiliriz bundan sonraki adım ise
bunları erkeğin tarihi olarak değil
cinsiyet eşitlikçi toplumsal cinsiyet
eşitlikçi bir dille tekrar ele alarak
bir yere varabiliriz Çünkü
sümerlerin icat ettiği milattan önce
3300 lerden günümüze kadar gelen 5300
yıllık yazılı tarih doğum öncesindeki
göbeklitepe'de Karahan tepede çıkan
yazılı kabartmalar ve motiflerimiz de
gösterdiği bir şey var tarihi erkekler
yazıyor tarihin erkekler tarafından
yazıldı bir dünya sürekli olarak ordunun
silahını ve ölümünde yüceltir
düzeltildiği bir alandır ama biz bu
tarihi cinsiyet eşitlikçi bir
mentalite ile bir mantıklı bir bakış
açısıyla tekrar yazarsan 21. yüzyıldan
28 29 yüzyıla önemli bir Yankı
oluşturacak ses bırakmış oluruz bunun da
bu temelde ele alması gerektiğine
inanıyorum ekolojisi bakacağız
yaşadığımız coğrafyaya gılgamış'ın
söylediği sözlere ve gılgamış'ın
söylediği sözlere değil gılgamış'ın
mesela büyük özelliği nedir Arkadaşlar
yeni evlilerin ilk gece
gelinle beraber olma hakkını kendisinde
görmesidir işte tarih gılgamış'ın
cümleleriyle değil o ilk gece zorla
Onunla beraber olunan gelinin söylediği
sözleri Biz dinlerse bir gün cinsiyet
eşitlikçi ve daha toplumsal bir tarih
anlayışı yaratırız diye ümit ediyor ve
inanıyorum teşekkür ediyorum ben çok
süre bağlı konuşan birisi değilim mı bu
olmasıdır bu